[Music]
so
[Music]
are you ready are you feeling it do you
have hot takes are you sitting next to
king josiah no that's just me what is up
welcome to take masters the only show
that allows you to fire off hot takes
and then get judged by two esteemed take
masters i and the l e f k o e man
you the legend
i'm king josiah i don't have a thing to
go after that j o s i a h man okay
turn up how about that
six letters i want y'all to know out
there he had no prompter he can win off
the dome with this thing a lot of your
favorite talent could not do that no
they they can barely i just can't read
that's the issue here uh welcome to take
masters hello everybody in the br app i
have the br app open we are looking at
your comments we are judging you but
most importantly we are looking for hot
fire
this is the american idol of sports
takes do you watch steven a and get
annoyed because you think you can roast
him do you watch max kellerman and go
what a square
that might be us but like that thing
right this is your opportunity to fire
off takes we are going to be showing a
bunch of takes
our big question today
is who is the most important person in
the nba playoffs and we don't want joel
embiid
we don't want you to say luca
give us a sample not your main take but
give us a sample of some takes that
you've seen that you go oh i like that
one well look we all know the most most
important person is lebron raymond james
senior because if he's not in the
playoffs that means that your team may
have a legitimate chance of winning a
championship but if he's lurking or
lingering obviously no injuries aside
then you don't have that opportunity hmm
i was going to say the person that
tweets for magic johnson okay because
those magic
come on magic is pacing around his
office going tweet this the memphis
grizzlies just won which means that
they're up one nothing which means that
they have a chance to win the series
send tweet that's what we got going on
and then as the takes get made josiah
might throw in a gif
and then we're gonna react but we see
you in the br app uh the scoring this
week
we changed it up we changed it up we're
not doing one through ten and all the
scoring we are simply giving one of two
reactions a good reaction after last
night a pat beverly smile can we see
what that might look like
just a happy face
just pat beverly going out there and
taking his shirt off and crying cat
kissing his girlfriend feeling good and
if we don't like the take also from last
night
jay-z scrunched stink face
it stanked on it
before we start the show can we talk
about the timberwolves and pat bev now
look obviously we got to roasting on the
internet got the jokes off but i was
super happy for him to get the seven
seat
it was just a little a little too
dramatic beating the clippers it was so
good like jersey off can i tell you that
i was in my hotel room and i was
watching this i was like wow this is
incredible and then inside the nba
started and then chuck and shaq and
kenny just started roasting them and
even ernie was like wow shortest season
ever and i was like that's why inside
the nba is incredible because we're all
here being like wow look at this scene
and then they were like yo why are they
celebrating so hard it was the pan from
him crying to carl anthony towns kissing
jordan woods where it was like the
balloons tipped it was perfect
they came with one shiny mama i think
lebron you know laughing emojis coos
congrats on the championship it was just
but it was great to see that everybody
was locked in and timberwolves fans barf
lying and everybody else out there we're
not taking away from your moment yes we
want you guys to enjoy it but you guys
are way too turnt up for the seventh
seat but i get it i'm a lebron lakers
fan not in the playoffs can't talk and i
look i understand that carl anthony
towns fouled out with like seven minutes
left and you probably thought that there
was no chance but i mean
i agree why are we being so sensitive
take these jokes you won if there's a
time to take the jokes
the whole
let us enjoy this moment was nonsense
timberwolves fans
this is a part of being an nba twitter i
know you have not experienced this often
but enjoy this this is what we do we
clown we throw out jokes memes
everything obviously mine are tasteful
and respectful
paper was out there super turned up i
respect it but now you got to go deal
with these memphis grizzlies who also
talk trash
and pat bebe's big footsteps aren't
scaring anybody the fact that there are
tweets
of pat bev
coming at john morant yeah and now they
get to play each other
phenomenal pat is in trouble great
basketball though i'm excited to see it
ja
you know grow men with twisties and cuts
in their eyebrows always make me a
little nervous so hold your wallet
really go out there and get buckets uh
we have six takes that people have sent
in my note to everybody watching the br
app right now if you would like to have
your take judged on the next episode of
take masters when we put this out on
twitter when we put this out on ig
send in a 20 second video dm it two
bleach report on those two platforms and
you will have a chance our first one
today
i don't we haven't seen them we don't
even really know what they're about so
let's set it up the first take master
submission let's take it away who do we
got
all right most important person during
this emmy play
gotta be kd's pr manager we need them to
take away this man's phone put in a safe
throw in the ocean whatever they have to
do to make sure kd is offline we need
him on zero dark 23 or whatever lebron
used to do because we need kd's solely
focused
on getting buckets instead of worrying
about internet dudes
okay
so k garris 14 his pick for most
important person in the nba playoffs is
kd's pr manager saying that he needs to
be focused
um
i'm going to give my thoughts before i
give my score
so my first thought is
i like the creativity i like the notion
of not picking kd but his pr person my
initial reaction though is i think
kd's therapist is twitter and i worry
that if you take his phone away and he
keeps all of that inside
i think it's like a dam you're building
it up and i think it needs to get out uh
what are your initial thoughts to this
can we show that the the gift that i've
pulled
for this particular moment and that'll
basically encapsulate everything that
i'm thinking while we're waiting for
that to come up not a good take k.d is
literally the king of twitter he's the
king of nba twitter the man needs it
he's jumping on spaces while he's eating
food in between games he's not
moisturizing his ankles because he's too
busy firing off tweets let the man live
let him do whatever he does to stay
normal obviously lebron famous for
cutting off social
hasn't really done much the past few
years might as well get on there we saw
lebron was active last night he was
socially active last night the same way
kd needs to be let katie get the slander
and now if you want to you know more
burner accounts
let them be but i need to see kd doing
it going at people
nick wrights and everybody else out
there you just nailed it
i think that and i'm going to give my
grade i'm going to give it one pat bev
and i'm going to give it three jay-z
snarls
so i'm only giving four i don't know if
that's the correct math but my my main
reason is i'm giving it to pat bev
because they went pr
if the rest of the take was to shut down
the burner accounts okay and to only
focus on the main account i i could have
given it two bat bevs but i think that i
think we're in alignment here i think kd
needs to fire off tweets to be full
okay easy money sniper i'm gonna go
ahead and give it
five jay-z's
wow not a good and i respect the
gentleman who gave the take i understand
where he was coming from wow
but k.d slander katie needs to be on the
internet how are you going to slander
people on twitter for talking about him
if he's not on twitter he needs that
motivation that drive now he could do it
less frequently and we all know that k.d
is tweeting from his own account which
is why i respect him as well right as
you mentioned like you know magic other
guys may have teams tom brady we already
know he's not firing any of those tweets
off so as much as i love tom brady's
tweets they're not coming from the goat
himself i hate when people are like man
tom brady's undefeated they you should
lose twitter access for a full day if
you think that tom brady is actually
firing off those tweets now has he fired
off one or two maybe but i feel like
there's a whole process now
kevin durant can't say that erica badou
is thicker than a kindergarten pencil
what he might not put up 50. i missed
the old days of twitter when it was like
48 000 retweets way more likes everybody
was just hitting that retweet button
[Music]
you think now that people are avoiding
retweets
out of jealousy i don't know i think the
algorithm changed back in the day we
were a lot more comfortable hitting that
retweet button more people need to do it
what is kd's avatar right now
is it still is it is it still not is it
smalls from uh yeah
from um
sandlot and what's that is like one of
my favorite movies but we're on tv and
i'm nervous you can see i'm perspiring
just a tad wow when do you ever see a
tweet get 52 000 retweets and likes
that's what i'm saying it's a good old
days the algorithm's janky now shout out
to kd though always keep it real always
shares his feelings and
that's why we need him on twitter um
man
uh that's okay so kd so you gave it five
jay-z's i gave it one uh pat bev and
three jay-z's for the first one okay not
a great start that's a lot of jay-z's
but look
take may be so bad that it's good and
you still might get elevated just
depending on how we feel and again we
are picking two of our takees to reach
the finale of the take masters uh to
then uh argue with us and each other i'm
just gonna check the br out really quick
um
see what we got here
copying lebron flattery at its finest
uh
the the bronze sexual calls k.d king of
twitter lol that was from j dilla
would you consider yourself a bronsexual
i don't know that's literally the
corniest worst name i could like i don't
know where the bronze sexual thing
started but it's time to end it all
right yeah we all have players that we
support we like
whatever yes did lebron call me the goat
yeah he has a good taste he's not the
only one i'll just say that i can't
believe you got that from lebron a lot
of people can't but i knew this lander
was coming i knew the trolls when he
tweeted you did you get alerted on your
phone
i actually saw it
actually randomly i think like kyle long
or somebody hit me like yo like sorry
you got the brown reach i'm like what
are you talking about then i saw it
and uh you know i knew i told my wife
like i was going to be great
personally professionally but also the
slander see you were calm
yeah for sure okay
i was honestly more disappointed that it
took him so long
let's go to our second take submission
of the night here on take masters
and i hear that it is about chris paul
let's see what angle they took the most
important person in the nba playoffs has
got to be chris paul's doctor because if
chris paul with his thumb if he doesn't
come back at 100 the suns are straight
trash brothers straight trash they got
no chance of winning the finals if he
doesn't come back right they're done put
all the resources in that doctor good
luck
can you replay i just want to replay
like the first five seconds and i'll go
like this when we're done i just want to
hear something one more time the most
important person in the nba playoffs has
got to be chris paul's doctor because if
chris ball with his thumb if he doesn't
come back at 100 the suns are straight
trash brothers straight trash
for a second i thought he said the
thunder but he said the suns are and so
i wasn't sure um zibby
do you know zibby i don't know zippy but
i love that he came through with the
trash prop we we had this with our last
take masters where there was a
basketball being shot by our young dude
and there were props involved and so i
want to give props to zibby uh for
involving something else straight trash
which means he started it
and then he thought that the beginning
went well enough to drop the paper my
question is how many times do we think
we went for this uh i'm going to give
the the
my initial thought is chris paul's
doctor
okay
it's a good person
um in terms of the execution of it if
he's not healthy the sons are straight
trash he kind of tailed off with it um
i
what i'm noticing right now is initial
good thoughts
but
but not great execution
and not good follow-up points but i did
like his prop so as i think about my
grades your initial thought of this take
look i think the suns obviously need cp3
to get over the hump but the team was
solid when he went out obviously still
retained that one seed only team the nba
to win 60 games this year right unless
i'm smoking's recreational and i'm not
in california so i don't think that's
the case
um
yeah i i i would say it's going to be
tough for them anyway i don't know if
they can beat the nets i don't know if
they can beat the bucks because they
didn't do it last year
so i'm gonna say it's a good take
love the prop i don't know what kind of
trash it was look more like tissues and
as we all know tissues are not trash
they're very valuable
and it was more litter than trash i'll
just say that um
i i'm like sitting here thinking about
what other angles he could have taken
because i my take has always been that
chris paul getting hurt right before the
all-star break
was the smartest thing that he did
because he got his injury out of the way
early
chris paul's doctor
uh i'm actually gonna go
i'm gonna stay a little bit true i'm
gonna go one pat bev and i'm gonna go
four jay-z's okay so because i actually
like kd's pr manager more than this so
i'm going one pat dev four jay-z's i
just and and i'm also yeah
he didn't land the plane josiah he
didn't land the plane and i i didn't
desell it in flight he could have he
could have he could have gone and been
and been like
he could have gone some ah it just
didn't stick with me i'm sorry i just it
did not land with me shout out to the
production team too they got movement on
on the the animations you guys are doing
a great job i'm going to give it
two backpacks two pad bevs and three
jay-z's i'm gonna call the pat bev's pbs
from now on because it just flows better
like the idea the concept of it uh i
don't say the suns are straight trash
without cp3 now are they
elite level not necessarily but
yeah but i rock with dibby though that's
a great name
save you out there getting it in these
streets dane said kendall jenner is the
most important factor and that is
another person that i think could have
been brought up here legs are important
i will say that uh you know they
probably need to sleep in separate rooms
like a boxer cold water the ice do what
you got to do
uh dan duvall and we're seeing this here
uh that is right there cp3 is always
injured so it doesn't matter a sean
which is former br guy and i love
actually has insight here the sons
famously have one of the best medical
staffs in the nba shaq used to call them
yums young unorthodox medical staff
because they try experimental therapies
i think also what could have been done
here is
we could have the take could have
created a person it could have been like
uh you know chris paul's mythological
you know i don't even know here
look at cp3
we all know there's one person cp3 has
to worry about but i like getting bags
from bleach report turner so i'm gonna
keep my mouth shut you wanna give us a
hint no
i don't even know where you're going
okay tell me off the air we'll talk
offline okay now we are going
take number three
of six
and i have a note here and it says
syracuse i don't know what that means
that feels like home cooking uh as you
you know you went to syracuse i do know
that produced a lot of people in the
media industry so if you ever notice why
syracuse gets a lot more love than it
deserves because what i mean what are
you guys good at besides that shout out
to zav saying lefco uh please retire i
hate you
zav
thanks for watching uh let's get to take
number three and see what it is please
retire i hate you young and friends in
person in this year's playoffs is going
to be jimmy butler's anger management
coach
got to keep jimmy in check or that
locker room is going to explode down
there in miami
also
adam
go cues baby
can i start this one off
yes so there's my question
he said jimmy butler but he's obviously
wearing a dwyane wade jersey okay so i
gotta i gotta knock off a point for that
okay if he just went to the heat and
covered it or did something or did one
of those elaborate things where they
take the tape right
he gave me jimmy's number but i do
respect the
the carmelo anthony that was since
that's the last time the syracuse was
actually good at something i mean we've
been to final four since i'm not even a
big syracuse guy
like i have you been to final ones i
can't say things i have not been to
syracuse since i graduated they don't
they don't roll out the red carpet for
you no okay wow that's part of my issue
okay i get the same treatment from ucla
basketball social media team so we feel
the same way no acknowledgement no no
problem guys still here uh so i'll say
this one
let's focus on the take jimmy butler's
anger management counselor because if
not miami is going to fall apart
so
clearly channeling the fight that
happened earlier this year that jimmy
butler got into a fight with eric
spoelstra and then had to be separated
udonis haslam coming in separated
the the issue that i have with this and
i think the take could have been better
if it was flipped okay
the fight happened and then the heat
went on a five-game winning streak
and so i think the take could have been
his anger management person but
encourage him to fight more to create
anger that creates more winning i think
it could have been flipped
my favorite thing about this clip though
is fo wanted all the smoke and supposed
like what five seven five eight
when it started you could see spo look
at him and go do you want to fight me
which is only said by somebody that
wants to fight lucas paul's got some
guns he does some push-ups he definitely
has a good ab routine and the udonis has
him the living legend
and i'm curious like i don't know who in
the league i wouldn't want to fight less
than you dinos has them
[Music]
but got to be somebody maybe like james
johnson or something i think he's like a
what a black belt or whatever it is he
is
so
i am going to say
and he he went and he came at me and he
tried to bribe me
and honestly
show love to syracuse i know they don't
treat you well but you gotta what do you
guys know i love people
the thing that i take more seriously
than anything is my pride as a take
master
and and i think i need to set a
precedence
that if you're going to come in here
and try and bribe me
with syracuse paraphernalia
i'm gonna go five jay-z's
that's what i wanted to see i am because
you cannot bribe your way
and talk your way into becoming a take
master
if you think you're gonna come in here
and be like hey
i like the eagles i might actually bend
to that one but
he went with syracuse
i'm going five and and christian i
appreciate it i know and i i appreciate
the prop but i felt like he was trying
to bribe me and that cannot be allowed
you gave him five jay-z's i didn't hear
that because i was too busy meme hunting
i you thought i was giving them five pat
bevs i had i had the meme ready it was
eagle-centric
two black gentlemen you thought that me
and you thought that i was going to
support it no i need to set a precedence
so i'm giving him i thought this is what
you guys were doing again i had the
eagles queued up because i know you're a
philadelphia guy
and
in your heart
your goal plates are in your in your
future yeah no swine
but uh i'm going to give him
one pat beb and four jay-z's
because like you said they went on a
five-game winning streak right
i think that anger's needed we all know
jimmy butler he's the man uh especially
when he's angry calling people out but
that's the thing is he wants him to not
be angry
i need more anger that's why i gave him
before jay-z the one pat bev because i
do rock with that carmelo anthony jersey
and i love seeing white men wearing
black people's jerseys that's just me
personally
what is he gonna wear bob cousy i don't
know a larry bird who jerry mcnamara who
else you have on that squad you have
some legends craig forth hakeem warrick
now mcnamara was younger right on my
trooping he was there he had six threes
in the in the finals
jerry with the g2 got to respect it
you're right if he had come on in like a
um
a max streuse jersey
uh
or a tyler hero jersey respectable um
but i do like that that that colorway so
i got to give it up to him for that all
right i feel like i'm being very harsh
but i i feel like he thought i could be
bought i feel well i thought he
do you guys have like a secret secret
cues dap or handshake that you guys do i
don't think you heard me the first time
i do not stand for cues like that okay
people come out of our fellow cousins no
we're learning something right now when
people come up to me and they're like
syracuse i'm not excited you're not like
dab that no because what happens is
people like you go oh you got like a
like a syracuse mafia so i'm like
number one i didn't get into new house
out of high school okay and so when i
got in there originally they were like
oh you're not actually like a syracuse
guy and i was like you're i guess i'm
not wow and so i've always had the chip
on my shoulder like i don't really claim
it like that i really don't i respect it
because now you're out there getting it
at a level higher than most syracuse
alum so
turn up you know talk to your friends
and then you have somebody like zavian
who
you know
he's he's homeschooled and he's
you know and he he spills on his shirt
when he eats and then he joins us in the
br app and he watches uh let's go see
like look at this that's a lot of but
he's a 305 guy left go let's fight let's
go can we fight no question mark on it
left coat double space kick rocks dude
how about this avian xavier next time we
do take masters and you submit a video
20 seconds all you got to do is submit
it i'll venmo you 50 bucks but you have
to allow yourself to get take mastered
and
if you don't want to
well then you have a problem let's go to
the fourth take here on take masters and
let's see where they go it's about the
celtics
the most important person in the nba
playoffs this year is the man who got
this boston celtics tattooed on his arm
the celtics have to win for him or else
what is going to happen
shame humiliation
regret those are words that humans don't
want to say the celtics need to win for
that guy
somebody could give me the information
of when that picture was posted because
i think it's important the boston
celtics at the start of the new year
began a a crazy run ima udoka turned the
team around they were like the number
one defense in the nba since the turn of
the year and i feel like this got posted
even before that
i love
this take a lot the most important part
march 22nd okay so it was later
otherwise on the run they were on the
run but if you look that is exactly like
how that banner would look
i love people that get these
tattoos before the playoffs even start
i'm not ready to give my grade yet
because the one thing that i'm trying to
factor in is the take itself so the
first one is the idea
the concept
tattoo guy the second part was they need
to win for him so it's like a motivation
what is your initial feel of this take i
do not like the celtics i do not like
celtics twitter
but i do have some level of admiration
and respect
for a human being that literally gets
the championship flag tattooed on their
themselves but
the likelihood of it happening is
embarrassing you can update the number
two three four you maybe could update
the to 30 22
and at least give yourself some leeway
but yeah i don't know and the redness of
the arm too you could tell that hurt a
lot i'm gonna go ahead and say uh
i don't respect the celtics but i do
respect that take uh
the gentleman put a lot of thought yes
and i appreciate that so if i had to
give it a score
i'm going to go
i'll give him two pat bebs three jay-z's
look at his grill he kind of looks like
uh harlow
is there a chance that he's actually the
tattoo guy
what if he is yeah oh he's the one who
has he's the one and see and now
now see now we're now we're be showing
why we're take masters for sure if he
would have started that
and then ended the video by turning his
shoulder into it and even if he just
sharpened it on there that's real now
you go from maybe two pet bevs to four
pat bevs
i also the reason i like this take is
if the celtics knock off the nets and
they advance i'm waiting for the local
news story where they find the tattoo
guy and they're interviewing him and
then he sits courtside i think tattoo
arm guy especially in a city like boston
could become a central figure remember
the old lady that was sitting next to
terry rozier when he was scary terry
that like mean that was a thing i'm
gonna give this
um
three pat bev's two jay-z's i thought it
was a good concept i thought it was um
pretty good reasoning
the two jay-z's for the lack of props
the lack of elevation
and the fact that like i know you're not
a big celtics fan i know that and i'm
not a celtics fan either i respect it
though i respect every aspect of nba
twitter
uh definitely love email adopting what
he was able to do with the squad this
season and i definitely deserve more
love in the coach of the year
discussion but
it is what it is
i respect the guy though all right so
that one i felt like kind of hit a
little bit so i like it that was take
number four and i wonder do tattoo guys
have relationships with the tattoo
removal people is that kind of i feel
like there's a scam or hustle you're
right we have not gotten a follow-up
on all of the other tattooed people that
it didn't follow through and i want to
whoever tattooed i'm still wondering i
don't know if you remember the person
that got drake like tattooed on their
forehead
when you when they come in there and
they ask for that this is the person
it could be his cousin
oh man
sons out gundog wait what was the drake
one though somebody got like drake
tattooed on their forehead
and drake got really mad about it oh my
gosh but when you go to a tattoo artist
and ask for that
like do they just laugh in your face
like there's only probably like a couple
places in boston where you actually get
that legitimately and they'll do it for
you but knowing that you have to do the
sucker
uh jamal williams 671 saying every
celtics fan reminds me of the sons and 4
punching guy
that is a good take now if you would
have made a video you could have got on
the show
and you might have got some some fanfare
and some love out of me
um man oh wow
but honestly wow drake has that that
type of impact on people so
that is so regrettable
could you make a take to why that tattoo
is a good tattoo are you such a take
master that you could spin that i mean
if you're going to marry a guy named
drake maybe
but the k looks a little janky it's like
yeah and they need to do a little
follow-up on it could you imagine
getting drake's tattoo on your forehead
and then drake comes out and says he
doesn't like it like the only thing
you're hoping for is drake is like come
to my next show like that's lowest
lowest fruit is backstage passes that's
yeah not even a ticket like general
population unfortunate man all right
let's keep it moving take number five is
about james harden and the philadelphia
76ers let's see where they go the most
important person in the nba playoffs is
james harden's barber period there's a
lot of pressure on hardin to perform
right now and everyone knows the saying
when you look good you feel good aka
play good and harden's not going to play
well if his beard is lopsided flying in
the wind this picture of his beard you
see the straggler on the left this is on
april 7. they lost now this picture this
beard it's perfect the 76ers won this
day there's obviously a massive
connection here
[Applause]
i i
want you to go you're a sixers fan
though sorry i knew you were gonna love
this one from the jump i did appreciate
how she came through with like the tick
tock green screen i can't do any of that
stuff but i love when they make the
videos where they point to whatever is
going on
and i was going to say i don't think
that james harden uses a barber but now
that i've seen the groomed beard versus
the unground beard
very valid point i want you to know that
my reaction my standing ovation and the
grades that i'm about to give have
nothing to do with the fact that it is
the philadelphia 76ers there's nothing
to do okay it has everything to do with
what we saw is that james harden
it is that's a that's a beautiful beard
wow
there was little editing
there was a full presentation it wasn't
like hey i hope i do a good 20 seconds
then there was evidence no
there was hey bad beard lose good beard
win there was presentation there was
delivery
i am giving this
five pat beds
i'm giving this five beds whoa what you
just witnessed was a thought out take
that was produced delivered edited and
executed that is why there are five
things five pat bev smiling
and
just like the minnesota timberwolves and
pat bev's i'm probably a little bit over
hyped than i should be right now jump on
the table take the shirt off throw it
into the crowd wow i'm gonna give her
three pabs two jay-z's
what a hater the russian judge but this
is also why you're a take master so what
was missing o master i'm just hating uh
you know i'm just really still salty
that lebron lakers aren't in the
playoffs so i'm just taking that out on
all of our take master guests but i did
appreciate the editing the tick tock
style of the video and the nuance points
and i actually interviewed james
harden's mom years ago during the
lockout like 2011 and his kind of beard
was still growing at this point she
basically said that when he was at
arizona state he always looked super
young so he wanted to grow the beard out
right
and i think at some point he's gonna
have to shave that beard and are we
gonna be able to recognize him like what
does james harden look like underneath
that beard now
uh so zavian when you end up doing your
take this is how it needs to go okay use
like the one or two brain cells that are
still functioning do a little bit of
editing maybe write words down i know
that's tough for you you can finger
paint if that's easier for you process
it complete thoughts and then deliver
and then prepare to catch these hands
but that was phenomenal p motz that was
great and
there's another sixers take
we have one more six
yeah but okay but your c i'm not gonna
be that easy of a grader if it doesn't
deliver all they got to say is sixes and
they're already getting at least two pad
bebs out of you now i'm going to prove
you wrong take number six let's get to
it let's get it
me personally i'm going with joel
embiid's uber eats driver
joel b is the type of guy who needs a
snack a burger some chicken wings right
before the game so that driver is gonna
have to be vigilant so he can stay
energized during the playoffs
okay so the pettiest la
legend by the way
he is about to order a snack as well
because my man is toasted
okay
can we he can use a californian we do
things in college and it's legal can we
just watch the beginning of that really
quick and just see the smile on his face
it could be a sun glare it could be a
lot of different things me personally
i'm going with joel the way he said
personally me personally
oh he needs a snack a burger okay so
all right so was he projecting burger
chicken wings that's what i'm saying
these are what he's look at his face
right there my man is feeling great um
i want to know
why
the concept of joella mead's uber each
driver made you audibly laugh for the
first time today we have heard a lot of
other people when you heard that you
giggled why because i'm a postmates guy
but i did respect the the nuance the
thought that went into it
uber each driver just the fact that he
would have uber eats not a door dash guy
not a grub hub so many different options
but we think like the third tier food
delivery guy we think about embiid he
would definitely have something going on
the men's eating grapes and shout out to
the pettiest big big heavy and laker
nation uh makes a lot of great content
for the internet
appreciate them sending that in
i'm gonna rock with it i'm you know look
for the first time i'm gonna give i
think three pat bebs i don't know if
i've done that yet your first three pack
beverages i'm gonna give them four let's
get four pad babs wow i'm cooking just
like you gave the five pack babs to the
sixers tech i'll give the four pat bebs
at this one um
so
i like you
heard joel embiid's ubereats delivery
driver and i went okay where is he going
to go here
the
landing of the plane
as
because he's hungry and needs snacks
i i
didn't really feel it
just because
we're all hungry we're all like snacks
i'm hungry right now i'm gonna keep it
real i'm gonna i'm starving
i'm gonna go
um
two pat bev's three jay-z's
because sorry patty he got you
and and listen patty i i i appreciate
what you did for us i think it was great
uh and i i cannot stop staring at your
face
and so actually i'm gonna switch to
three pat bevs and two jay-z's sorry to
our graphics solely because of this face
right here look at wow look at the team
again they did that so quick
they're on it they're actually watching
the show listening when i used to be on
that side i would never pay attention
i'd just be mf'ing talent underneath my
breath
and talking down them thinking we didn't
have social media like that back then we
only had facebook
it's a different time uh but the
pedestal a i appreciate you uh what do
you think we've seen uh joella mead
right here eating grapes eating a burger
what do you think joelle embiid's like
go-to meal is i think he's gonna be
eating an l in the near future
[Laughter]
i don't know man um that was good if i'm
embiid i would say
so look everybody was like pat and jim's
or the the the cheesesteak spots yep but
i got one in chester last time i was out
there i forget the name of the spot but
it was phenomenal definitely have a
grease stain ruined a nice pair of
shorts with the the cheesesteak grease
and there's nothing that beats the
cheesesteak it's delicious whoever came
up with it salutes you
um
we are now
we're going to go to um
before before we bring on two of our
takis and it's it's less to crown as it
is to have some constructive feedback
fight to the death um we are also going
to share some of our own takes
um
i'll go first
i believe
that the most important person in the
nba playoffs
is the masseuse
of one luca doncic okay
i believe
that
luca
has a chance
to be
a dwayne wade
or another one of those
superstars that came out of nowhere in
like their third year and and we weren't
expecting it just like dwayne did with
the heat against the mavs and i think it
would be very interesting if that
happened again but it's
a swedish woman named olga
that's going to put that pointy swedish
elbow right into lucas calf and unlock
it and have him doing that face and luke
is going to be sitting face down on the
table just going
and he's not going to be able to handle
it but he's going to get up he's going
to rotate his foot and then he's going
to drop 45 on the jazz and that's where
it's interesting is i think lucas dwyane
wade moment comes against the team that
dwyane wade owns and it's all because of
olga yogastrimski
and that is the woman that's going to
put her elbow into lucas calf and i
think that is the most important person
in the nba playoffs and i believe that
you have a gift uh that you can see it
so i can't get your response right away
but you saw it getting typed i'm just
going to say i don't know about that one
chief
luca look he's going to be a star one
day you mentioned dwyane wade dwayne
wade had sort of prime shack
a little yeah
so i'm gonna go ahead and say i don't
know about that one chief but uh look i
respect it hopefully luke is doing well
jason kidd obviously caught the ire of a
lot of mavs fans with the decision to
play luca in that game
and it's tough when you see those things
happen and it's like damn is our season
over but i think we'll have enough time
to rejuvenate get loose but then they're
not going to get out of the second round
let's just keep it real so no matter how
good that masseuse is he's getting
bucketed could you imagine if he took
down like the suns by himself and if
luca beats the sun
in that discussion yeah i will say that
he's better than trey at that point um
but it's not gonna happen so i don't
have to say you have trevor luca right
now i rock with trey though
i i rock with trade too you know my
affinity for light skin and hoopers with
the the big armor cracking do uh i'm
rocking with trey i just was never a fan
when it was like you know luca kind of
started off high and it's like oh
there's no way the trey's on that level
trey gets to the eastern conference
finals what else you want to see from
yeah all right so what is what is your
take before we get to uh our take
submitters so my take the most important
person in this playoffs is going to be
ben simmons now we've seen ben
rocking the gray the green leather
during the playing game lambskin was it
lambskin lambskin prada wow 100 lambskin
this any of that type of stuff though
i'm like you know there's going to be a
lot of stickage in the thigh areas
sweatiness but i'm getting high right
now i'm wearing a t-shirt so i respect
the look but like i said last night i i
would appreciate it more if he was just
in like sweats and a dingy shirt like
look i'm getting a treatment issue with
guys wearing really nice clothes on the
bench when they're not going to play
it's like kendrick now was wearing the
like the red eddie murphy pants it's
like great looking outfit kendrick
number two you have not played a game
all season but you know that he is
wearing that for whoever is sitting
across from him in the front row when
he's waving and being like check your
dms like that's the point of that right
it's a great fit great fit to wear out
to the clubs or whatever you're going to
do but it's a fit i need to see after
not in brooklyn drop 20 to 30. that's
not right
that's one of your like l.a club outfits
but that's why we have more swag than
you guys i mean debatable but that's a
take into itself it is but you think so
you think he's the most important
because if he plays if he plays nets are
going to win the championship wow if he
doesn't play giannis
um
we are now going to go
to one of our takis okay up for this
sessions take master without telling me
who it is let's pop this person up and
let's see who we have that has made the
cut according to our producers have they
tabulated all of the pat bev heads who
is our first taki submission
who do we got
oh wow
i am so happy on the stroll are you at
work right now you took a break to be on
the show tell the truth
i did no i'm go i'm walking to the
dentist
okay well all right get it in dentist
give us your name
and the and and how much research did
you give did you put in for that james
harden take
i'll get out of your way um so my name
is paige
um i would say i put in quite a little
bit of research
i looked you know when when the
when the 76ers won when they lost i
checked out his beard and then i made
the comparison i noticed that
you know common denominator
i have never given five thumbs up before
and i just want to know your reaction
did you think it was going to be that
good are you impressed or and josiah did
not give you five pat bets i didn't know
about that
oh my god uh well first of all that kind
of upsets me i thought it was pretty
good but i also was a little surprised
um i thought that everyone else had you
know really good ideas too so i'm
flattered
um you're someone with great wi-fi
you're getting dental work can you share
with the people what dental work you're
getting done at crown root canal what's
going on just a general cleaning what do
we have going on
um i've never have a cabin in my life
weird brag
will brag like that's pretty cool no i'm
just going for like you know you're a
yearly you go like once every six months
or a year i'm just
being uh
you know on top of things
all right well be careful because
they're not forgetting you they love to
dip into that you know if you have
health coverage
reach that maximum i'm like oh you need
this that or whatever yeah don't fall
for the 400 whitening that they're going
to offer you for no reason uh
and lastly your your
reaction
whose take was better lucas masseuse or
ben simmons from us
um you guys for sure
well which one lucas masseuse or ben
simmons bent on black bet on black ben
simmons ben simmons
that was good that was good so paige so
you just how far away are you from the
dentist how many blocks
um it's on 24th i'm on 14.
you know we've got 10 bucks stay on for
like like two more minutes
do you know what's hilarious about new
yorkers you guys walk everywhere
i would have drove that 14th 24th
stepson
sounds like a great drive no way 10
blocks is perfect uh asia do we have
anybody else on the line or is that it
all right paige is gone
do we have one more or is that is that
our official winner all right we have
one more and this one might be more
oh the legend okay
so this is
boston celtics championship guy tattooed
are you related to that dude yes
uh i'm not and i do want to clarify i'm
a lakers fan i'm in los angeles right
now but i wanted to make my take
objective you know what i say i think
that's the point of it that's fine
that's fine influence so i had to tell
you jose as another laker fan just so
you know
the purple and gold sweatshirt
i like the sweatshirt it's phenomenal
wow okay balling appreciate it that
changed my opinion i would yeah i might
have to elevate him now you completely
have thrown off our judging system by
revealing that you are indeed a lakers
fan your reaction to our criticism of
your take after you heard that what
would you have changed
you know i do pride myself on
you know a take a good take and i like
my take but i really like your idea of
having a sharpie of that tattoo i think
that would have taken it next level
maybe even
go to take master tape honestly i'm not
confident but you live in you learn so
that's the what is your first name
stay on the line we're going to talk to
one more person eli thank you eli
sucking up to you with the lakers right
there that was a smart one winner in my
mind and so that means we have one more
person that we're going to check in with
so we have paige and it is katie's pr
manager what is your first name
um kendall
candle hey kendall the curl is fluffy
though i will say that it's elaborate it
is you know i'm a big advocate for curls
if i could grow my hair again without
the grain that's how you do it yeah for
sure all right kendall we we did like
your take but we actually went the
opposite way and said we needed kd on
social media when you heard that did you
agree with us or would you like to
defend your take
oh yeah i'll defend so i definitely
understand where you guys are coming
from like obviously like i love katie
talking about you know like the
discovery channel drinking scar joe's
bath water like all of that yes those
are classics but we gotta understand
we're going into the playoffs now you
know katie can be an emotional dude you
know hears everything he reads
everything
like i said take a page out bronze book
zero dark seven thirty five whatever he
wants to call it branded
be off because then if he's not on
social he only has two avenues to take
out his anger
on the court
which we all love and post game pressers
because we know kd king has some good
quotables
you know he has a good game comes out
hey you remember who i am i'm kevin
durant we're gonna get more of those
because you know we still are you a nets
fan
are you a nets fan
i'm not i'm actually a spurs fan but i
am a big fan of kd and so i want kd for
key performance and i'm like all right
this is year three of the nets i was
like haven't really come together yet
and so like this is the time where it's
like alright kd
this is your chance lock in and you get
back on social you can celebrate and you
can roast everyone you want after you
lift the lario
so what you're saying is
save those tweets so when you win the
championship and you can just come with
that hammer because for me i feel like
embiid with the the funeral treat when
ben simmons got traded
it's a little too early say that for the
playoffs save that if you beat the city
but you know you have to hit that beat
the nets
i know believe me i'm an engagement guy
i like getting old takes exposed because
they just continue to run the numbers up
and i continue to get jobs like this
that's what the kids don't realize yes
and i appreciate the way you defended
your take yep
i'm gonna i'm gonna i think what i give
i think i gave five j's these i'm gonna
i'm gonna go ahead and take a couple of
those back and give them two pat bebs
okay i wish everybody had that luxury of
coming in to defense it
but and i'm rocking with the crow twos
i'm getting three pack best wow
i like to take kendall off the screen
before josiah gives them another pat bev
the flossy curls are key
oh get them off thank you okay
it is kendall it is eli and it is paige
it is k.d it is celtics banner and it is
james harden beard paige is about
probably six blocks away from the
dentist right now eli's in the back
enjoying the purple and gold
two the last two played to you
and your sensibilities page played to me
i know you're rocking with pages as a
take master judge
there can only be one it is like
highlander there can only be one take
master
who is your official vote for i got to
give it look i love eli i love kendall
what they brought to the table i got to
give it to paige though
because she came through with the
editing she brought it to a whole nother
level let's bring her back on here on
her way to the dds it is our
responsibility to announce that paige is
the best paige this is your chance your
acceptance speech you are officially a
take master how does it feel
um well it's my first time so it's such
what a great experience thank you for
having me so much fun i can't wait to
submit my next
hot take
page is literally on the show you guys
have good wi-fi in new york though
because i could never i could never get
that off 5g
i got the 5g of course
all right so paige the one thing we'll
ask you is while the dentist is working
you need to tell him that you or her
that you won take masters today but you
cannot explain what it means you just go
i'm a take master and then don't talk
okay congratulations i will i promise
thank you so much
and a big congratulations to eli and
kendall for earning more um pat
beverly's after their takes
we are going to teach josiah eli kendall
come on you guys are great
submit takes next time as well
lakers takes will get the win anything
pro lebron pro brawny
pro savannah
pro zuri pro bryce rockin with be on the
lookout twitter and instagram
we don't know what it's going to be
about next time it could be nfl it could
be nba it could be about anything in
general the next time that we throw out
the take signal
20 seconds dm it to bleacher report on
twitter and ig for a chance to come on
and we are going to send them some swag
uh for joining us
take masters the second champion has
been crowned josiah are they all going
to meet up preferably in like the
bahamas or hawaii or somewhere like that
so we can all do it live
turn up as you guys know i don't think i
tell other people but i'm almost dealt a
gold status with my sky miles trying to
get to platinum heard great things about
it diamond i've heard is the best
so trying to get that going but send
those texts in we're not going to roast
you guys 20 seconds or less as you see
this we're very very very very very
friendly with the takes we get you know
there's no slander really unless you
just say some absurd off the wall stuff
but send them in we appreciate you and i
want to keep this going this is this has
been enjoyable we are enjoying it i'm
trying to find oh xavier and xavier and
again the offer still stands
50
for you to send in a 20-second take the
next time we do take masters and if you
don't do it
everyone in the comments section knows
that you're afraid and you don't want to
fall asleep thinking about that do you
you don't for king josiah i'm adam
lefkow this has been take masters be on
the lookout and we need your takes we'll
be back next time have a good day
everybody
[Music]
you